migration was expected to dominate and
it certainly did that's right Jane I I
actually thought it was a fascinating PM
cues not because of the facts that were
Unearthed during it about migration most
of those if you've been paying attention
to the government announcement yesterday
a sort of broadly in the public domain
but we sort of learned a lot about how
politics around this issue is going to
be conducted and I thought it was really
interesting just to observe the
different approaches of the two-party
leaders so what Rishi sunak was doing
was trying to emphasize the principles
here the he was trying to mind the
divisions between the conservative
position as outlined by him and the Home
Secretary Sola bravaman over the last 48
hours and the labor position which is
slightly less distinct in certain uh
certain ways so uh so Rishi sunak did
policy
kirstama did process he tried to focus
on whether the plans were deliverable he
sidestepped really what he agreed with
and what he didn't agree with and
instead he focused on whether Whitehall
was fit for us whether the government
had a good track record on uh delivering
these kind of policies in the past and
whether or not in practice it's all
going to work out now that what that
wasn't the only route he could have gone
down if you listen to the SNP uh
Westminster Lydia Stephen Flynn he he
attacked Rishi sunak on the basis of uh
policy he suggested that a woman who had
been trafficked came over on a small
boat would be subject to immediate
deportation and never be allowed to
claim asylum in this country he
suggested that the principle is unfair
but instead kestarma went all on whether
or not this was going to make any
practical difference so just hear a bit
of kirst armor
after 13 years
Small Boat Crossings higher than ever
claims unprocessed the taxpayer paying
for hotel rooms criminal gangs running
all the way laughing to the bank and an
asylum sister utterly broken on his wall
this is their fifth prime minister their
sixth immigration plan their seventh
Home Secretary and after all this time
all they offer is the same old gimmicks
and empty promises I don't agree with
the home sector on very much but when
she says that the Tories are all talk
and no action she's spot on isn't she
so you had a number of uh facts that
kirstama wheeled out four percent of uh
claims processed now that's down uh to
less than one percent uh and I think he
highlighted uh the number of people who
have been returned under the previous
Asylum system that the government had
run
um so that was uh Kirsten's uh plan of
attack Rishi Cenex well we learned a lot
there as well effectively this is going
to be an election dividing line you
could tell from the way that the Prime
Minister I mean bluntly threw the
kitchen sink at this one trying to
highlight all sorts of uh previous
things that kirstma has said about
migration basically making him out to be
in favor of open borders uh and then
rolling out this attack line uh of being
a lefty lawyer I thought Rishi sunax
contribution had all of the smell all of
the Hallmarks of being carefully focused
grouped designed to try and road test
some of the language that we'll hear it
all the way up to the election
suggesting it has to be said Jane uh
that this is as much if not more about
politics than it is every given the
tight time frame between now and the
next general election given it's going
to take months and months and months for
the legislation to pass politics here's
how Rishi sunak through the kitchen sink
at kiss Dharma
foreign
yesterday talking to our law enforcement
officials what do they tell me precisely
because of the law that the conservative
government passed last year they have
now been able to arrest more than double
the number of people they did before
397 in the last six months but stopping
the boats Mr Speaker stopping the boats
is not just my priority it is the
people's priority but his position
position on this is clear he wanted to
in his words scrap the Rwanda deal he
voted against measures to deport foreign
criminals Mr Speaker and he even argued
against deportation flights well and we
know why because on this matter he
talked about his legal background he's
just another Lefty lawyer standing in
our way
and I suspect we will hear that phrase
Lefty lawyer again and again on the
run-up to the election someone else
would be learned at pmq a couple of
issues that emerged on the side
um most strikingly uh a conservative MP
Miriam Cates asked the Prime Minister on
International women's day about uh
whether or not all schools were teaching
uh or some schools were teaching
inappropriate uh information or graphic
including graphic descriptions of oral
sex as part of sex education lessons and
the Prime Minister actually said that
he's asked the department for education
to ensure that children are not getting
information that is not age-appropriate
so it sounds like there's been an
announcement of a decision uh of a
government action that we didn't know
about in relation to sex education he
said he's bringing forward a review on
psh and uh so something uh to watch
there for uh interesting uh what's
behind that um what evidence they have
and what action is going to take be
taken about that and also right at the
start of prime minister's questions in
response to a question from Richard
Bergen the left wing labor mp uh
he'll be releasing his tax returns soon
so that's one two watchful